today we're going to be practicing
integration now we've mostly spent our
time so far in learning areas and
definite integrals and all the rest
working with functions you're very
familiar with integrating our basically
powers of X you know you'd have
polynomials like this if you were
integrating something like that you'd
have sums of functions so things like x
squared plus X cubed occasionally what
we would throw at you is something that
required the reverse chain rule so maybe
something like X plus 1 squared which of
course you could expand but if I change
that power to something gross like 20
and you only want to expand it but you
can still use the reverse chain rule
relatively simply and then sometimes we
would even throw something like this at
you this is not a polynomial when you
get fractional indices but you can still
treat it with the same derivative and
integral rule that we're normally
dealing with with powers of X so that's
kind of what we've been dealing with but
we want to sort of branch out into the
different families of functions that we
haven't looked at as frequently in
recent times so we need to sort of get
that part of our brain back in gear the
three families of functions we're going
to be looking at today are firstly
exponential functions make sense to
begin there because after you know these
powers of X these are the easiest to
deal with
e to the X famously differentiates and
therefore integrates back into itself so
we're going to have a look at those the
flip side of course of Exponential's is
logs but we don't integrate logs we
integrate to end up with logs so that's
why we deal with these families of
functions called rational functions
rational of course means just like the
rational numbers this is when you're
comparing the ratio of two functions
particularly when the ratio is comparing
a function and another one which is it's
derivative so actually if the derivative
is the one up the top and the one down
the bottom is the is the primitive so
this is going to end up with log of x
squared plus one as an example because
that's on the denominator and the
numerator is just the straight
derivative to X that's Exponential's and
and Long's rational functions which lead
to logs lastly today we'll finish out
with trig functions so in each case what
we're going to do he's a couple of
examples that are really
we straightforward and then we will go
into a heart of one for each case so
let's begin at the top with like I said
a fairly basic exponential function this
is your exercise to e and it's a
definite integral so how do we integrate
this well before I even begin I want to
call back all the knowledge I have about
differentiation and use that to help me
with differentiation so starting with
integration so what I've got here is an
e to the 2x
if I were differentiating e to the 2x
what I would do is I would use the chain
rule so I would differentiate the power
so or the index I should say so that's 2
and then I that I've dealt with the
inside part and now I deal with the
outside part which is e to the power of
something either part of something when
you differentiate that just leaves you
either the power of that same thing so
this would be the derivative now
remember when you're differentiating
what we do is we multiply through the
better color of it we multiply by the
derivative of the inside function so
since we are integrating here which is
exactly the reverse we are going to
divide instead of multiplying so what do
I get here well big square back it's
because I've got a definite integral I'm
gonna have not 2 e to the 2x but 1/2 e
to the 2x and you can quickly check in
your mind if you were to differentiate
this primitive the 2 from the 2x would
cancel with the 1/2 out the front so
you'd be good to go you would end up
with this either 2x like we expected
there's the primitive function now I've
got my boundaries naught and 2 and I'm
gonna now evaluate I should do one more
thing before I do that which is to take
that half out the front as much as
possible I like to simplify before doing
any substitutions or calculus because it
tends to make things a bit easier to
work with so that leaves me with just an
e to the 2x from naught to 2n now let's
do the evaluation so I've got the half
out the front eetu the power of 2 X will
be equal to e to the power of 4 when I
substitute in two and then I'm going to
have e to the power of 0 because 2 times
0 is 0 now a mistake that many students
make and I've made hundreds of times
over the years is that when you put in a
battery of zero when we're having a look
at these guys up here right it's so
common that if for example you take X
cubed on three if we were integrating
this with a boundary of zero either the
top or the bottom then you are thinking
oh it's zero cubed on three so your
substitute in zero you get a value of
zero and it's the same for many of these
right now that's a natural instinct you
get quite used to it it's a bit like
muscle memory when playing an instrument
or a sport and so here it's um it's easy
like I said I've made him say many times
of putting in zero and thinking that
that makes it equal to zero but it's
it's not you've got e to the for out the
front here but e to the power of 0 is 1
so trap for young players and all
players alike there's the value there
and looking at the original question
it's just asking us to evaluate this
integral so it's not asking us for an
area or anything like that even though
this could be an area so therefore I
don't need to put units squared or and
if you on the end it's done ok right
let's have a look at the next one now
there's a lot to take in here there's a
lot of a lot of symbols and the the path
through this question is not immediately
obvious before you have a look carefully
at what's going on here and how the
pieces fit together so let's step
through it one step at a time it says
find f of X so we need to find some
function our final line will be f of x
equals something or other and also find
like evaluate that function at this
particular x value in this case 1 if you
are given the function is derivative and
a particular function value over here so
let's think about this what I'm ending
on like my goal will be f of X and F of
1 and I'm going to have to use these are
the two pieces of information in the
question this derivative and also this
particular function value to arrive at
those so how do I do that well we know
that if you differentiate a function
that lands you in the derivative so if I
want to go in the opposite direction I
have the derivative to start with and
when you go back to the primitive so
therefore I'm going to integrate as we
are with most of these questions so I'm
going to start off by saying f of X is
equal to the integral
of F - with respect to X and of course I
actually know what F - is in this case
it's handed right to me e to the 1 minus
3x on D X ok so now I'm ready to
actually integrate like in the previous
question I'm going to use reverse chain
rule on this so I see the inside
derivative is negative 3 I'm integrating
so instead of x negative 3 I will divide
by negative 3 so that leaves me with
let's see here
e to the 1 minus 3x divided by negative
3 this is an indefinite integral so I'll
work that constant on the end here and
that's where as you can you might have
anticipated that's where this second
piece of information comes from to find
out what this constant is equal to I'm
going to need to use this particular
function value because otherwise C is
just unknown it could be anything okay
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna say
since this fact is true fact I'm just
gonna grab it from up here since this is
true I'm going to substitute this into
the previous line that we just worked
out I'm gonna substitute a third into
every value of x and that will give me
two thirds as as my value over here on
the left so I'm gonna put in two thirds
over there because I'm putting in one
third on the right hand side I've got e
to the power of 1 minus 3 lots of a
third there's that x value being
substituted and then that whole thing is
being divided by 3 okay so at this point
here I've got to be careful with my
simplification 2/3 is equal to e to the
power 0 on negative 3 plus my constant
and noticing that there's a 1 on the
numerator there I now can actually
collect my like terms and then make C
this subject so watch carefully this
negative 3 on the denominator I can
actually write it as a negative 1 on the
numerator as long as I cancel that other
negatives so therefore what I really
want to do is add a third to both sides
so if I do that I get 1 on the left and
C by itself on the right hand
so therefore why was I trying to find
this value well it was to put back into
my primitive function right up here so I
can put in plus one there and while I'm
at ER I'll also do the same thing with
this minus sign that I did when I was
working down below I'm gonna put it up
the top okay so that gives me negative e
to the 1 minus 3 X all divided by 3 plus
1 the constant I just found now I'm
almost done with the question I just
need to evaluate at F of 1 because
that's the particular spot the question
was asking us and of course like why
would you do this well it might be
useful if we were graphing this or you
might have some part two which compares
this graph to something else and you're
looking for a point of intersection
because then that will help you find the
boundary where these are where you know
one integral begins and the other one
ends so that's why we often do things
like that this question just comes
without any other context let's just go
ahead and evaluate I'm gonna say F of 1
in fact I'll put that one in blue just
so you can see the substitution really
clearly F of 1 equals negative e to the
1 minus 3 lots here comes the 1 again
there's my substitution into X that's
all divided by 3 and then I'm adding 1
well if I got here well it looks to me
like it's minus e to the 1 minus 3 all
over 3 plus 1 that gives me an e to the
negative 2 up the top and since I've
already written this as a fraction
because I have that 3 down the bottom I
might as well write that e term on the
denominator as well because that's
negative attached the 2 means I'm really
rather than multiplying by a twice I'm
actually dividing by a twice so I'm
gonna go ahead and say that's minus 1 on
the top in 3 e squared on the bottom I
guess I could go one better than that
and I actually could actually write the
positive term first and I'm pretty happy
with that it's done so looking back have
I actually done everything the questions
asking me it's not Mary or anything like
that I'm happy we got f of X we got
everyone done